no clear winner no surprise instability
is the result in this election boyko
borisov's center-right party won most
votes if he manages to get a coalition
together he says policy would remain
pro-european
Bulgarian needs to be very clear firm
and precise on where it belongs in the
European Union and NATO
succeeded borisoffers prime minister but
his popularity waned partly because of
his Hardline on Russia and his messaging
didn't get the support he needed they're
making a choice between the politics of
transition where corruption was part of
the brand with Bulgaria or a new
completely reformed transparent growing
Bulgaria it was only last year that
anti-corruption protests brought down
borisol's Government after more than a
decade in power his administration faced
120 allegations of corruption from an EU
prosecutor despite this borisov's core
support stayed intact mainly among older
voters many of them living outside of
the capital
he's very confident he's a
well-qualified politician he
communicates very well and he takes
advice from the experts
but University lecturer Galena pindikova
is skeptical about how there can be a
fully functioning government
they might form a government but it
won't last for long the last few
elections show that it's nearly
impossible to have a stable coalition
government
and so what next negotiations to try to
get a coalition government formed
parties with different ideologies trying
to come together it could include a
nationalist pro-russian party
but there's no guarantee it will all
succeed and there could be another
general election
Andrew Simmons Al Jazeera Sophia